where the [ __ ] are a party we'll see
how it goes
[Music]
the Betsy holiday party is a a grand old
tradition where you all get shit-faced I
had many tequila shots
they don't do shots I know you went to a
bar after the party oh my god
these lights feel wowed I might just
still be drunk I don't know if these
clothes match in my ideal world I would
have stayed in ordered takeout I just
need something greasy something
unhealthy I know that food after
drinking a lot of times can make feel
not great but we'll see how this how
this go it's hot right
oh it smells [ __ ] amazing
I feel like this is healthy and good for
you I don't I feel about that how I love
that oh that's so good it's lovely it's
warming me from the inside out that's a
body good hurts so bad because of all
the stability this is like really very
soothing I wish I was on my couch or in
my bed drinking this not here
[Music]
listen it may see something white and
runny this early in the morning I saw
one didn't get out
I love congee I mean it's basically like
porridge I don't know how I saw in feels
about this makes me feel better without
like making me feel like I'm gonna be
sick and this is like healthy hangover
food
I actually don't hate it it's kind of
good when you're hungover you want to do
minimal amount of chewing well I'm all
about swallowing oh yeah I should
recognize this tea ooh
green tea I love green tea yes it's not
like snapping me out of my hangover
right now that's like a punch in the
face
oh this is nice this is nice can I live
here can I just like move in right here
to this spot I love it it's delicious I
feel healthy balanced basically gonna
start a fitness blog now oh this is you
get out
hey Junko whoa
it's basically like vegetables meats
kimchi and something else this is more
my jam right wait this is my jam are
those little blood cubes excuse me what
is a blood cube what do you think a
blood cube is I don't know if it's
because like I just grew up with this
but this hits the spot
oh yes spicy yes this is what I this is
what I need it don't ever feel less
hungover mm-hmm but it kind of was like
a nice shock to the system it's for sure
the best hangover food we've had so far
yeah wait I think it's our smells like
vodka if it's vodka I'm gonna throw it
at you Oh
coconut water am i trash everything is
smell like vodka Cheers
I thought it was gonna taste like normal
water yeah it's good it's bearable I
would just like some normal water hmm
all these dishes are for sure healthier
than like your typical American hangover
food it's good for when you have a
hangover and you want to crawl into a
ball and cry but you have to be a
productive person I do actually feel
better I don't feel as like the pounding
in my head is subsided quite a bit
ginseng tea that was really good yeah I
think that was my favorite I can see how
that doesn't rain I would order that
Korean soup yeah any day of the week
that's a mess one that one's my boat
this is lovely I recommend a five-course
hangover cure honestly I'm starting to
feel better like it's actually working
[Music]